Hi.
I'm Christina, product manager
for the Google App Engine
search API.
In this webinar, we'll provide
an introduction to the Search
API and show you how to use
it in your App Engine
application.
The Search API lets your
application perform
Google-like full-text searches
over structured data and also
supports GeoSearch for
location-based searches.
It provides a straightforward
model for indexing and
searching data and displaying
the results of search queries.
Using the Search API, you can
query any data source you
choose by creating
search documents.
You structure data in documents
using fields to
describe the different types of
data the document contains,
and then add the document
to an index to make it
searchable.
Once documents are indexed, you
can search an index via
the Search API's comprehensive
query language.
When you query, you can specify
sort orders on the
results, control the
presentation and content of
the search results with features
like snippets, and
use cursors and offsets.
The search API can be useful
in a range of applications,
like user review search,
searching over blog posts and
comments, document discovery,
help desk answer retrieval,
resume search and recruiting,
and product searches in an
online store, the example
application
we'll use in this webinar.
In this webinar, we will
highlight the features of the
search API and get you started
on adding full-text search to
your own App Engine
applications.
We'll start by looking at
defining search indexes and
building documents, and then
move on to querying, sorting,
GeoSearch, and, finally,
best practices.
For the purposes of this
webinar, we'll be using
Python, but the flow in
Java is quite similar.
And Java code snippets
can be found at
fts-webinar.appspot.com.
This webinar assumes that you
have familiarity with building
an App Engine app in either
Java or Python.
For more background on App
Engine, see our documentation
at developers.googl
e.com/appengine.
At the end of this presentation,
you'll find a
resources slide with links to
the documentation and other
useful sources of information.
So now, I'll hand it over to
Amy, who will demo some of the
full-text search features in a
sample application and walk
you through getting started
with the search API.
AMY UNRUH: Hi.
I'm Amy, a developer relations
engineer working on the App
Engine search API.
We're going to use an example
product search application to
illustrate some of the features
of the search API.
This application shows how you
might use full-text search in
an e-commerce application.
We've indexed two general kinds
of content in this app,
product information and
information about stores,
including their geographical
location.
The application allows a user to
find products by searching
and sorting the product content
and to use GeoSearch
to find stores that carry a
given product near to them.
So we'll do a short demo first
to introduce some of the
features covered
in the webinar.
This is our demo application.
It has two example product
categories, books and HDTVs.
So it's kind of a small store.
And it contains index product
documents and index store
location information.
OK.
So let's do some searches so
that you can get a sense of
the query language and the
search API features.
For the purposes of this demo,
we're going to show you the
query as is, including the query
operators, so that you
can get a sense of
the language.
For a real application,
you would obscure
that from the user.
You wouldn't expect them
to know the details
of the query language.
I'm going to start by submitting
an empty query.
This retrieves all of the
documents in the application,
sorted by their average
rating.
You can see there are
only 12 of them.
Now I'm going to filter
on books,
filter on product category.
So here's an example of
filtering on a document field.
Now let's sort on price.
So as you can see, we can
sort on different
aspects of our documents.
And you'll note that we have
support for pagination.
All right.
Now let's do something a little
more interesting, add a
search term, "stories."
I'm going to
sort my query by relevance.
So what this does is it uses a
TF by IDF score to sort, term
frequency by inverse
document frequency.
So this is finding documents
that are particularly relevant
to our search.
And notice that we're displaying
only a snippet of
the description fields.
And that the hit on the term
"stories" here is bolded.
So let's look, just very
quickly, at the product
details of the top two
hits for that search.
And you'll see that this first
hit has a number of instances
of the word "stories"
in the description.
And you'll notice that the
description is longer than the
original snippet that we
were just showing.
And if we look at the product
details for the second hit
here, you'll see that we only
have one instance of the word
"stories." So we're sorting the
documents by relevance.
And we are auto-generating
snippets with the hits bolded.
And the snippets are showing
where the hit was in the long
description.
All right.
Now let's look at Boolean
operators.
So if you just type in
some search terms--
I will type in "stories"
and "novels"--
this is an implicit "and"
of these terms.
And you'll notice that we
don't appear to have any
products in our store that use
both those terms together.
So now let's use the or operator
and do an or query.
And then we get some results.
So we have some documents with
hits on one or the other of
those terms.
And you can see, again, the
snippeting is showing where we
got the hits and is bolding.
You can also restrict a search
term to a specific field in an
index document.
And we'll talk in more detail
just a bit later about what we
mean by fields.
So let's look at the syntax
for doing that.
One of the fields in our product
document is the Name
field, the product name.
And I'm going to search for
documents that have the word
"the" in the product name.
So you can see we're getting
some hits, Otherwise Known as
the Human Condition,
for example.
You can combine searches
on name fields with
other terms, like this.
So I'm looking for documents
that have the word
"collection" somewhere in one
of their fields and have the
word "name" in the product.
And you can do searches for
fields that aren't in all of
your documents.
So, for example, our book
products have a publisher
field, but our TVs don't.
So we can look for something
like this, publisher Penguin.
And there's some of
our hits for that.
And search API also supports
atomic fields, which must be
matched exactly.
So this means that you can't
search for just a substring in
that field.
You need to search for the whole
string to get a hit.
And our categories are
atomic fields.
And that's because we want to
search exactly on categories.
We want to treat them
essentially as a token, or an
innumerable.
You can also use numeric
comparators.
So you do this by using the
field name in the expression.
So price is one of
the field names
in our product documents.
And so we can do queries, like
price less than $20.
And as before, you can include
use of these numeric
comparatives with other
search terms.
So now we're looking for all
products that have the word
"novel" where price
is less than $20.
So this demo showed you some
of the features and
capabilities of the
search API.
We'll come back to the example
application a little bit later
in the webinar to show you
a few more concepts.
So now let's look at how you
can add full-text search
capabilities to your
own application.
We'll start with indexes.
Start by looking at what a
search index is and how you
add content to an index.
The search API operates through
an index object.
And an index allows you to
store content and index
documents, retrieve documents
using search queries, modify
documents, and delete
documents.
So each index has a name and
optionally a namespace.
The index name uniquely
identifies an
index in a given namespace.
In your code, you create an
index object by specifying the
index name.
The underlying document index
will be created at first write
if it does not already exist.
So you don't have to explicitly
create it yourself.
So let's look at what this
looks like in your code.
First of all, we import
the search module.
And here, we're creating an
index object with name
productsearch1.
The second line here shows what
the code would look like
if you wanted to specify a
namespace that the index was
associated with.
Next, let's look at how
to add searchable
content to an index.
You do this using documents.
Documents hold an index's
searchable content.
So you add a document
to an index.
And then once it's indexed,
you can query it.
A document represents a
uniquely identified
collection of fields.
And it's identified by
a unique document ID.
Fields are named typed values.
So some of the field types
that we're using in our
example application are text
field, number field, date
field, and atom field.
And all of these are pretty
much what you would expect
them to be.
The documentation provides
a lot more information.
So I wanted to particularly
comment on atom field, which
is essentially an innumerable
or a token.
You only get a hit on an atom
field if you search for the
entire string, not
a substring.
So let's look at the structure
of the product documents in
our example application.
We've got two different
categories of products, books
and televisions.
And each product document always
includes certain core
fields, which this figure
is indicating
by these boxes here.
So some of these core fields
are product ID, name,
description, category,
price, date, and the
rating of the product.
Then the televisions have some
additional fields, such as TV
type and brand.
And the books have
some additional
fields, such as publisher.
And so we're imposing the
structure, the semantics, at
the application level.
So in our example application,
product documents always
include the same core fields.
All televisions always have
the same additional
fields, and so on.
The documents themselves in
the search API do not
intrinsically have kinds
in the sense
of datastore entities.
You impose semantics on
these documents at
the application level.
So you can use namespaces and
indexes, as well as field
values, to organize
your documents.
In the example application,
there are two indexes.
All of the product documents
are in one index.
And another index, which holds
information about store
locations, we'll talk
about a little bit
later in the webinar.
So let's take a look at how we
build a product document.
The first thing that we do
is to find the fields.
And then we create the documents
from the fields.
So in our example application,
we're using text fields, atom
fields, number fields,
and date fields
types for product documents.
And in particular, worth
commenting that we're using
atom fields for the product
categories names.
This means that if we search on
the category field, we need
to use the exact category name
string, not a substring, to
get a match.
So atoms fields can be
particularly useful for things
like categories, where exact
matches are expected, and
where we don't want to
match on substrings.
And text fields can be better
for things like titles and
descriptions.
So, given the fields, we can
create a document object.
For each product document, we'll
set its document ID to
be the known, pre-defined,
unique idea of that product.
And if we did not specify the
document ID, one would be
auto-generated for us when we
add the document to the index.
And so this is what the
code looks like.
We have built the
product fields.
We're creating a document object
using those fields,
using that content.
And in this case, because we
have unique product IDs for
each of our products, we're
setting the documentary ID to
be that product ID.
OK.
So we've looked at how to create
documents from fields
that hold the document
content.
And now we can add
them to an index.
Let's look at how to do this.
This allows the documents to be
searched using the Search
API's query language
and query options.
So here, again, we've created
our document.
Now we're going to use the add
method of the index object
here to add the document.
And the results of doing the
add are an interval.
In this case, we've called
it add result.
And you can extract the assign
documents IDs from that
interval, as we show here,
with the results return.
So if you didn't assign the
documentation ID to a
document, then this is how you
could obtain the document ID
that was auto-generated.
And if you did assign a document
ID, like we showed
here, then what would
be returned would
be that same ID.
So when you do a document add to
an index, be sure to catch
any exceptions at result.
Here we're catching search dot
error, which is a general
Search API exception.
All right.
So let's just take a quick look
again at a product detail
page from the example
application.
And this is showing, just for
demonstration purposes, the
raw field names that we're
using for this document.
And obviously, you would not
want to expose this in a real
application.
And so you can see that these
are all of the fields that
we're using in our documents,
and you can see their content.
And you can add documents one
at a time or you can add a
list of documents in batch.
And that is more efficient
if you add them in batch.
So far, we've talked about how
to build indexes and build
documents and add them
to the indexes to
get queryable content.
So next, Ged is going
to talk about how to
search over our indexes.
GED ELLIS: Hi.
I'm Ged, a software engineer
working on the App Engine
Search API.
By adding documents to an
index, we have made the
document content searchable.
So now we can perform full-text
search queries over
the documents in the index.
There are two ways to submit
a search query.
Most simply, you can pass a
query string to the index
search method.
Or you can create a search query
object and pass that to
the search method.
Construction of a query object
allows you to specify query,
sort, and result presentation
options for your search.
First, we'll look at how to
construct simple queries using
both approaches.
Then later, we'll look at how
to perform more complex
queries using the
query object.
A query string can be any string
that can be passed by
the search API's
query language.
See the search API's
documentation for a detailed
description of the
query language.
The query string should
be a unicode string.
The example looks for products
that contain the terms
"writings" and "collection."
The query string is passed
into the index object
search method.
It's here.
And then later we'll see how to
process the search results
that are returned.
A search query object gives
you more control over your
query options than does
just a query string.
Here we first construct a
query options object.
This argument specifies that
the query should return a
limited number of results.
Then we construct the query
object using the query string
and the query options object.
We then pass the query object
to the search method.
Once you've submitted a query,
search results are returned to
the application in a search
results object, which includes
the number of results found,
the documents returned.
The number of results returned
is the length
of the results property.
The number found property is
set to the number of hits
found in the search.
The returned documents are
accessed by iterating on the
search results object.
You can then access the
properties of the document,
such as doc ID and fields.
As we have discussed, you can
submit a search query using a
simple string or, alternatively,
a query object.
The query class constructor
takes as arguments a query
string and query
options object.
The query options object allows
you to configure a wide
range of options to fine-tune
your search.
Let's take a look at one
of the query options
configurations used in the
example product search
application.
Here, we are setting a query
offset, a limit, and some sort
options, and a list of snippeted
fields, and a list
of return fields.
Let's take a look at what each
of these properties do.
To control the number of results
that a query returns,
use the limit parameter of the
query options constructor.
In the example product search
application, we used limit to
return, at most, three
results per page.
We also used the offset
parameter.
The offset indicates the number
of matched documents to
skip when returning results.
The limit and offset parameters
provide support for
pagination in the product
search application.
To implement pagination, we
also need to know how many
results were returned from
this query and how many
matches were found in total.
As we saw earlier, we can get
the information from the
return search results object.
The use of snippeted fields
allows you return an
abbreviated snippet of a field
instead of its full content.
And if your search query has a
match on the snippeted field,
then the snippet will include
the fragment of the field in
which the hit occurred and will
highlight in bold the
search terms in that fragment.
In the product search
application, a search query
returns three hits in the
document's description fields
because we requested that
description to be snippeted.
The snippet expressions in the
results have "stories"
highlighted.
You specify the snippeting that
occurred by specifying
fields to snippet.
In the product search
application, we request
snippeting of the description
field.
Then, when you're processing
your query, you can access the
generated snippets
from a return
documents expressions property.
The expressions property holds
a list of computed fields
which are the result
of expressions
requested in the query.
This includes snippeted
fields.
So here, we're graphing the
snippet generated for the
description field of a document
returned by the
search results.
The returned expression property
allows you to define
computed fields based on your
document fields that are
returned as part of the
scored document
in the search results.
As a simple example, suppose
that we want to calculate
prices, including sales
tax, for our products.
Suppose the sales tax is 8%.
We create a search field
expression with the name
adjusted price, whose value
is price times 1.08.
After including a returned
expressions list in our query
options object, we can access
that computed field in the
documents returned from the
search query via expressions
property, like we did in the
generated description for
field snippets.
We've now looked at some ways
to define more exactly the
documents to be returned
from a search.
But we haven't yet
discussed how to
order the query results.
You can sort on a field value,
as well as expressions that
include the field value.
Sorts can be multidimensional,
sorting first in one field
expression, then on another,
and so on.
In addition, you can sort on a
score based on the documents'
turn frequency by inverse
document frequency ranking.
Or you can make use of that
score in a more complex
ranking expression.
Let's take a look at these query
sorting features now.
The sort options class provides
the basis for
defining query result
sort orders.
A sort options object, once
defined, is used as the sort
options parameter of a query
options constructor.
A sort options object can be
configured in a number of
different ways.
Let's take a look first
at match scorer class.
It is used to sort documents in
descending order, using a
score based on term frequency
via document frequency.
This sort is used by the example
app when the user
selects relevance from the query
sort menu in the UI.
To use match scoring, a match
scorer object is passed as the
match scorer parameter of the
sort options constructor.
You can also pass the sort
options constructor and
expressions argument, which
is an iterable of
sort expression objects.
This lets you perform a
multidimensional sort based on
the document field values.
Let's take at look at how we're
using sort options in
the example application.
We define a sort expression
object for each product
document field that we plan
to use in the UI as
an available sort.
For example, here are the sort
expression objects for the
price, product name, and
average rating fields.
For all of these definitions,
the expression parameter here
is simply the field name.
As we'll see shortly, the
expression can be more complex.
We define the sort direction
for each search field.
For example, we're sorting
price and product name in
ascending order.
With average rating, we want to
sort in descending order.
Since this is the default sort
direction, we don't need to
specify it.
We're also defining a default
value, which is used if a
given document doesn't include
the field in the expression.
For a string-based field like
product name, the default
value must be a string.
For numerical fields,
it must be numeric.
We create a sort options object
with the expressions
parameter set to its list of
these sort expressions.
And as before, we pass the sort
options object to the
query options constructor.
The expression property and the
sort expression object can
be more than just
a field name.
For example, we can access the
document score in the sort
expressions.
This is done using the special
construct underscore score.
The sort expression sorts on
the value of the average
rating field plus the
document score.
If you access underscore score
in a sort expression, your
sort options object should
include a scorer.
So here we've concluded the
match scorer object.
And now my colleague Bo is going
to talk about GeoSearch
and best practices using
the Search API.
BO MAJEWSKI: Hi.
I'm Bo.
I'm a software engineer
on App Engine working
on the Search API.
I'll take you through
location-based search.
Location queries are what allows
you to find all nearby
restaurants or all nearby
[? string ?] objects.
In order to execute a
location-based query, we need
to have three pieces
of information.
First, we need the point
from which we're
measuring the distance.
We also need to have some sort
of distance, such as 10
kilometers or 10 miles.
Both of these are usually
supplied by the user.
The last piece of information is
the set of points to which
the distance is being
measured.
This needs to be a set of
documents, which represent
some real-life objects.
In our case, stores.
First, let's look at the
location search in the
application.
We found the product, the book
Runaway, and we want to
purchase it.
So we initially enter 20
kilometers radius and try to
look for all the stores.
This finds some stores in
Mountain View, some stores in
Sunnyvale and San Jose.
We can widen our search,
make it 40 kilometers.
This time, we find pretty
much all the
stores in the Bay Area.
And since it's a particularly
nice day, we might try driving
even further, so now we are
looking for everything within
100 kilometers.
And it finds one store
in Carmel Valley.
So let's look at how
to include this
information in a document.
Location is defined by a
GeoPoint class which stores
latitude and longitude.
The latitude specifies the
angular distance in degrees
from the equator.
And the longitude specifies the
angular distance, again,
in degrees, from the
Prime Meridian.
For example, the location of the
Opera House in Sydney is
defined by a GeoPoint minus
33.857, which is the south,
and 151.215 west.
You learn that to start GeoPoint
in a document, you
need to add the geo field with
the GeoPoint set at its value.
Once the documents are
constructed and added to the
index, we are ready to run a
search query against it.
A GeoSearch query uses the
distance function, which takes
the field name and
the GeoPoint.
The field name is the name
of the field that you are
searching on.
The GeoPoint identifies
the location from
which you are searching.
We compare the value returned by
a distance function with a
distance specified
by the users.
If you were in Sydney Opera
House, say, listening to
Puccini's Tosca., And
experienced a desire to locate
the stores within
4.5 kilometers.
You would use the
following query.
You would enter distance from
store location from a GeoPoint
that identifies the
Sydney Opera House
is less than 4,500.
And this is measured
in meters.
Running the query against the
index would return all
documents for which store
location field records a point
that is less than 4,500 meters
away from Sydney Opera House.
Getting all stores within a
given instance is nice, but
what would be even better is if
we could sort them by how
far we need to walk or drive.
This can be done by adding
a sort expression.
Again, assume that the user is
browsing store location from
Sydney Opera House.
The query that finds the stores
within 4.5 kilometers
and sorts them by a distance
from a user
would look as follows.
The query string remains the
same-- distance from a store
location to a GeoPoint
is less than 4,500.
What we add is the sorting
expression, which asks to sort
by distance, again, from
the same point
based on store location.
We sort in ascending order,
which guarantees that the
stores that are closest to
us are returned first.
This concludes our quick
overview of the
location-based searches.
Let me talk about some best
practices for Search API.
We did not provide a separate
update document operation.
The semantic of an index is such
that adding a document
with an existing ID
simply updates it.
But it also means that you
should manage your own
document IDs if you plan
updating documents.
Managing your own IDs is also a
good idea if your documents
represent some external
objects.
For example, if you have a
document that is a searchable
representation of [INAUDIBLE]
entity, you could set the ID
to the key of the entity.
When you search, you can ask for
the index to only return
document IDs, and then convert
them back to the entity keys
and retrieve all matching
entities.
With regard to index name, it is
more efficient to have one
index per user than one large
index and store owner
attribute with each document.
The only time you could consider
having one large
index is when you need to find
all documents regardless of
which user owns it.
Each document has a
rank attribute.
If not set, it is assigned
a time the document was
added to the index.
The documents are presorted on
rank, both in ascending and
descending order.
If you do not specify the
sorting criteria, it will
simply return documents in
descending order of the rank.
This is the result of having the
freshest documents first.
If you have one simple order,
say rating, in which documents
should always be returned,
you should
assign rank value yourself.
This significantly speeds
up your search queries.
If you plan to insert or delete
a large number of
documents, please use
a task queue.
This allows you to control the
rate of insertion and to retry
some documents that did not
index due to transient errors.
Atom fields is our version
of enum values.
Atom fields must be shorter
than 500 characters.
However, they are
not tokenized.
As a result, atomfield full
space bar is not the same as
atomfield full comma bar.
You can even use them to do
your own tokenization by
inserting repeated
atom fields.
However, please remember that
this comes with a price.
And now off to Christina for
some closing remarks.
CHRISTINA ILVENTO: So
that about sums
it up for our webinar.
Thanks for watching.
To learn more about the App
Engine Search API, check out
our documentation and sample
application and ask any
questions on Stack Overflow with
the Google dash app dash
engine tag.
Happy coding.